oh oh okay great yeah so today i'll be talking about um trimeric april CAR-T cells for multiple
myeloma and an ongoing phase one clinical trial that we have going on at mass general
so you know a lot of people in this room their like life goal is to improve CAR-T cell therapy
especially from the efficacy point of view and so there's different ways that we can do that
yesterday i talked about consolidation after CAR-T cell therapy we're hearing about adjunct
therapies during CAR-T and you know this session and other sessions are about novel CAR-T cell
therapies and so there's different approaches to novel CAR-T cell therapies we're hearing about
dual targeting approaches um we're also hearing about novel car binding domains like with anita
cell with the d domain and so this CAR-T
cell product i'll be talking about is both it's dual targeting and uses a novel car domain
so back to the basics of bcma and plasma cell biology
soluble april is made in the myeloid cells and the stromal microenvironment in the bone marrow
and after it's made it trimerizes so it forms a trimeric formation and then it signals through
a bcma and tassie and it's the natural ligand for both bcma and tassie and it helps plasma cells
proliferate and grow and it's important for myeloma proliferation as well and that was really
the basis behind this novel CAR-T cell product called triprol this was developed at mass general
by marcella moss in her lab and it actually uses three versions of a truncated april protein
as the car binding domain and so this is not an antibody based car this is a ligand based car
and rather than one of the april ligands it's three to mimic that trimeric formation of april
that happens in vivo so you know why do we want to do this what are the advantages
so one is that as a ligand-based car it provides a different immunogenic pressure
than antibody-based cars and the trimeric form we found uh actually had higher uh binding avidity
and activity than just using a single monomeric april uh car why do we want to use this april
protein well it targets both bcma and tassie so we just heard about the advantages of a dual
targeting car approach may help mitigate antigen escape and tassie is actually a
unique target we don't have any other car uh any other therapies in myeloma that target tassie
and we found in uh in vivo models that these triprol CAR-T cells both eradicated bcma positive
myeloma cell lines as well as bcma negative cell lines showing that you know even if you've lost
expression of bcma through you know prior bcma therapy or tumor heterogeneity this CAR-T cell
still worked in vivo
this is the basis of our phase one clinical trial of triprol and patients with relapsed
refractory multiple myeloma we've studied two dose levels we did a standard three plus three
dose escalation and now we're on dose expansion and actually this is a homegrown CAR-T cell
product it's actually manufactured at the dana farber harvard cancer consortium and
that allows us a lot of flexibility our aphoresis to infusion time
has been as short as 16 days with a median of 29 days and we've enrolled uh 14 patients and 13
of them have gone on to receive triprol CAR-T cells and importantly we have a good cohort of
patients who have had prior bcma therapy so when we look at our baseline characteristics we do have
high risk disease so 46 of the patients had high risk cytogenetics 30 of the patients had extra
capillary disease and then when we look at their prior therapies 62 had prior bcma CAR-T cell therapy
and three patients actually had prior Bispecific exposure as well
just quickly going over the safety you know we haven't seen any
dose limiting toxicities in our primary endpoint for this phase one trial um and we've seen crs in
most of the patients although no high grade crs we had one patient who had very transient grade two
hlh which resulted with steroids alone we do see neutropenia and thrombocytopenia associated with
the lymphodepletion we haven't seen any non-icans neurotoxicities no parkinsonism no cranial nerve
palsy we haven't seen any enterocolitis so the safety profile has been very encouraging
and we've also seen a high response rate so in the total cohort we've seen a very high response rate
the overall response rate was 85 with a cr rate of 54 and this was consistent across the two dose
levels we studied 100 million cells 300 million cells and then also if we look at prior patients
who've had prior bcma CAR-T cell therapy the overall response rate was 75 with a cr rate of
50 which is comparable to the overall cohort in our you know swimmers plot we have seen some
patients have had longer response rates and we've seen a high response rate of 75 with a cr rate of
50 with a cr rate of 50 so five of the 13 patients have had responses over six months here we see
that there's a few patients earlier in their treatment journey so we'll see where they end up
and it's still ongoing our follow-up we looked at CAR-T cell expansion and persistence and we see
pretty good expansion and most of the patients we see persistence over three months and the
patients who are responding but you know we have had two patients who have been refractory
and so we've been looking at the mechanisms of refractoriness of resistance and this one patient
i think is worth highlighting so this is patient four this patient had a prior bcma CAR-T cell
therapy 10 months prior they had initial good CAR-T cell expansion but it didn't persist and the
patient was refractory so when we look back at their plasma cells at at screening they actually
the plasma cells did not have expression of either bcma or tassie and then we did ex vivo studies of
the CAR-T cell expansion and we found that the patient was refractory and the patient was
CAR-T cell activity and the CAR-T cells work ex vivo so this is really a you know a failure of
the patient didn't have or the myeloma did not have the target antigen and that's something i
think we have to be mindful of for all of our cell therapies but we have seen you know responses even
in extramedullary disease and after prior other t cell redirecting therapies so for instance this
patient patient nine this is a penta refractory patient they had prior cell to cell and had
progressive disease within a year they had prior talcetamab and had progressive disease after only
six months and they went into triperol with extra medullary progression and you know it's always good
to see some encouraging imaging so at baseline they had significant retroperitoneal soft tissue
periaortic extra medullary disease we were already seeing resolution by month one which continued and
improved by month three so um you know i think one of the points that made is that you know dual
targeting it might be especially good for
extramedullary disease so you know just briefly we've been seeing safety we've been seeing a high
response rate we're doing more work on you know mechanisms of resistance but it's encouraging that
we're seeing responses even in patients who have had prior bcma CAR-T cell therapy and other t cell
redirecting strategies um so we're excited to continue uh investigating this further thanks